raconté qu'après agitée et vous inviter
à boire un verre dans son bureau
non il m'a arrêté à débriefer encore
d'accord c'est débriefer ok très bien
pour moi ils ont de la chance je ne fais
jamais de les briser
munis de briques et de débris donc ils
sont tranquilles ils me voient même pas
ouais il me voit sur le plateau de clan
mais série confié je ne fais pas des
mets donc nous booster pour un débris et
sans vous adresser la parole il aurait
fermé la porte à clé et aurait surgi en
face de vous pour tenter de vous
embrasser alors qu'il venait de baisser
son pantalon
en les rappelant vos relations avec la
chaîne ppda se sera arrêté vous aurez
reconduite à l'ascenseur moi j'ai envie
de savoir mais rien c'est vrai que c'est
un truc de fou parce qu'on travaille et
quelqu'un c'est quoi votre réaction à ce
moment là où dit mais qui sait ce qu'est
ce que vous dites quoi vous dites fois
alors moi je travaillais pas avec ppda
je n'étais pas à la rédaction comme
l'avait dit j'étais un des mes légendes
de tps donc j'étais pas contenté la
rédaction ce qui s'est passé c'est que
après un festival de cannes où il est
beaucoup mieux sur les plateaux tps
puisque on organisait des plateaux à
l'époque
il m'a fait il a demandé à une de ses
assistantes de m'appeler
quelques mois après et donc la question
de cette assistante étaient s patrick
demande si vous avez déjà assisté à un
journal en direct bon j'avoue que la
question m'a énormément surprise parce
que franchement effectivement bon
d'abord ça faisait pas partie de mes
fonctions ni de mon intérêt ni d'un
désir ardent d'être sur un chat aux
pouvoirs magiques et est donc bon ok
j'ai accepté je peux vous dire que ça
m'intéressait tellement peu que j'ai
oublié d'y aller certes le soir venu je
me suis pas présenté sur ce plateau est
donc deux jours après elle m'a appelé en
me disant vous attendu et j'essaie
d'écouter je suis désolé j'ai oublié et
elle m'a dit mais non dans ce cas là
nous reprenons rendez vous voir moi qui
croyait avoir échappé bon je dis ok et
je suis donc allé et effectivement il
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé ce que
j'ai raconté partout où je passe
commande raconter à nouveau mais c'est
vrai que c'est une situation très
particulière et récurrentes d'installer
quelqu'un sur un plateau sans dire
bonjour derrière une caméra pour qu'on
le voit lui derrière les caméras et pas
le jt et puis à la forme j'étais
quelqu'un qui vient vous chercher parce
qu'il vous a m'a pas dit bonjour ni au
revoir quelqu'un qui vient me chercher
en l'occurrence une assistante pour vous
dire il vous attend pour des préfets
mais ce n'est pour des oui et ce qui est
intéressant quand on entend à votre
témoignage est celui des autres
plaignantes c'est une sorte de mode
opératoire qui se dessine c'est
qu'au-delà des agressions sexuelles à
chaque fois il prétexté une raison
professionnelle pour pouvoir vous parler
de débrief ça peut être aussi de jeunes
motrices qui écrivait des livres s'était
jamais demandé directement il y avait un
prétexte professionnel c'est ça à chaque
fois alors il y avait pour moi je pense
qu'avec quelques terrain de jeu
privilégié pour
mes cheveux poivre d'arvor il y avait
une jts que c'était effectivement d'une
très grande facilité d'un était sur un
jt des jeunes femmes les autres hills
qui avait besoin conseil qui était
forcément ravi d'assister peut-être à ce
jt puis après il y avait le terrain de
jeu qui était celui où la
systématiquement la procédure était de
la même le procès s'était même le jt
après le jt le bureau après le bureau
ferme la porte il se passe si ce parce
qu'il y avait d'autres terrains de jeu
aussi avec les terrains de jeu de tous
les événements culturels où il était
systématiquement couvent y est il y
avait les terrains de jeu des
des salons littéraires bon lestat j'aime
pas me dire les ciblent les personnes
les plaignantes et les personnes
concernées sont toujours à peu près
issus de ces milieux là littéraires
journalistiques très jeune la plupart du
temps vous avez vu les photos elles ont
20 ans 22 ans 23 ans et vous l'avez dit
quoi sont la justice m oui dites quoi
ben moi j'ai été extrêmement surprise
comme vous
vous dites quoi le roi du jt qui en deux
secondes d'abord serna porte à clé alors
que personne ne ferme la clé la porte à
clé enfin je sais pas si vous fermez vos
potes elle en moellons moi je vous dis
un truc à moi ma porte en fer dont elle
se fait automatiquement
non non je vous jure que c'est vrai que
cette personne avait personne n'a le baj
le premier vous mais moi pour vous
protéger gré parce que je ne cache pas
que j'ai énormément de succès
[Rires]
lui rien aux maisons qu'en fait il ferme
la porte à clé et puis et puis en moins
de temps qu'il faut pour nous dire il
est en caleçon mais ça et donc donc je
suis stupéfaite par ce geste totalement
disproportionnée des places et
pathétique mais en plus je muriel où on
voit muriel ccc une femme de caractère
ce qu'il fallait c'est quelqu'un d
extrêmement intelligent et réfléchi et
je suis un peu bas et reconnaître oui on
connaît les lieux en commun c'est vrai
que moi je me dis ne rien vous qui êtes
assez cash c'est quoi votre action vite
quoi pas je lui dis que je lui dise que
j'ai dis partout où je lui dit mais tu
connais mes liens tu connais mes
relations tu sais très bien que je ne
veux pas autant que j'ai déconné mais
lien avec la présidence les salles a
stoppé net ouais mais c'est directement
à la stopper net et sert à payer et nous
sommes sortis j'ai pris l'ascenseur mais
n'y a jamais eu de jeu de séduction
entre vous avons annoncé mais il y en a
pas eu avec moi comme il n'y a pas eu
avec pratiquement toutes les toutes les
plaignantes toutes les victimes saisir
que et d'ailleurs il a le même processus
c'est-à-dire que soit il invite dans son
dans son bureau et il n'y a pas de jeu
de séduction du tout soit et et
personnalise les personnes je sais pas
si vous avez regardé complément
d'enquêté effectivement il ya cette
jeune femme qui raconte
chez radio classique qui dit on peut le
voir si vous l'exigez l'excès oui ou pas
bonne muriel voyez vous pouvez être co
productrice pourquoi
béatrice mandine a travaillé à ses côtés
pendant quatre ans et dans leur studio
elle dit avoir vu le ballet des jeunes
femmes recommencer ça arrivait assez
souvent je dirais une à deux fois par
semaine et à chaque fois
ce qui était frappant c'est que c'était
donc
tout des jeunes femmes très apprêtée
très joli il les faisait
s'asseoir en studio sur un tabouret
voilà au bout du studio pendant pendant
une heure et il ne 13 ans elle ne l'est
présentée par me disais pas main
béatrice qui présentent les infos et
mademoiselle et je n'ai jamais osé
moi m'adresse à elle j'ai je m'en veux
de ça j'aurais dû parce que elle était
souvent
très intimidée elle s'était
dépersonnaliser gens n'aiment pas de
prénom
[Musique]
merci merial en tout cas d'être là on
voulait revoir ce témoignage est et
c'est vrai que après il ya énormément de
gens aussi qui disent qu'il y avait une
énorme aussi de 2,2 de deux femmes qui
étaient celles huit pains par ppda moi
c'est d'abord c'est passionnant de vous
entendre c'est vraiment une danseuse
d'alert mais moi je voudrais savoir
parce qu'on on décrypte son mode
opératoire à lui et moi je voudrais
savoir de votre point de vue à vous
c'est à dire vous êtes une très belle
femme vous êtes brillante vous avez une
assise professionnel vous n'avez pas
envie d'y aller et pourtant vous y allez
pourquoi on y va en fait pourquoi pas
au journal de 20h de ppda parce que je
dirige enfin je suis bon vous sentez
obligé en fait il sort dans prison
journal non monsieur non mais surtout
depuis mai gérard oui mais pas ça c'est
intéressant mais sur un disque ssd juste
à elle mais on va aller dans le groupe
il invite avant le jt de lui dire non ça
m'intéresse 300 ou même parfois vous
trouvez ça corrobore je ne vais pas la
première fois
on était franchement voilà comme du jour
est fait pour n'importe qui c'est très
intéressant tout est extrait qui est
passée là parce que cette façon de
dépersonnaliser personne c'est une façon
de les humilier il faut bien être
conscient et dans le dos qui a aussi
d'autres éléments qui sont très
important c'est que quand il n'a pas ce
qu'il veut il se venge vous souvenez
aussi un siamois n'y âge qui dit m et
pourquoi vous l'avez prise à vous donc
ya enfin voila c'est quand même
extrêmement personnalité extrêmement
complète de toute puissance il ya un
profil de personnalité de tout puissant
mais rien après quand vous sortez de la
loge où il raconté à des gens sont au
menu non je les raconte et j'ai appelé
le lendemain matin
je veux donner la seule léa clara
président oui et puis moi je alors à
tort je m'en suis plus préoccupé vous
êtes passé à autre chose de dire non
parce que c'est vrai que je ne savais
pas vraiment où je n'étais pas
confrontés à la rédaction s'était pas
remonter jusqu'à moi enfin je veux dire
les plus doux et plus et plus de
nouvelles de lui après anon leur après
c'est technique c'est je ne vous connais
pas c'est à dire que ni vous croisant
des cocktails ce qui est fait avec ce
qu'il a fallu tout on a d'ailleurs dans
mon canton ne majorent la retenue après
vingt-cinq nom à l'époque c'était 23-23
témoignages il dit ne pas connaître les
plaignantes c'est à dire que après ce
qui s'est passé il ne connaît pas les
femmes avec qui il a eu ces agressions
et c'est violent parce qu'il ya cette
plainte pour viol aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on ya vingt-six témoignages
17 plaintes dont 7 pour viol donc vous
voyez c'est pas un épiphénomène et je
devais à ma porte je vais m'arrêter de
pas en avoir parlé justement mur et la
paix parce que vous êtes dit si j'en ai
peut-être parler il y aurait eu voilà
vous êtes vous ai dit peut-être d'autres
on aurait parlé avec moi mais si j'en
avais parlé
et d'autres d'autres d'ailleurs
plaignante ait d'autres victimes se
disent la même chose c'est à dire que
l'on ne peut pas empêcher d'avoir peut
pas nous empêcher abandonné d'abord un
peu ce sentiment alors capabilités c'est
peut-être un mot trop fort mais ce
regret de ne pas avoir été au delà de
cette simple prise de parole parce que
effectivement il y aurait pas eu
d'autres victimes après si la chaîne
avait agi alors je vais vous dire ils
n'ont pas jugé paul affaires boutons ne
sont pas à alger pour les affaires de
plagiat ils vont pas agi non plus pour
la fausse interview de castro de gaston
est ce que là il y aurait eu une
réaction moi ce qui m'interroge
profondément aujourd'hui je ne dis pas
que les gens savaient ce que je dis
c'est que il y avait tous les soirs un
défilé incessant permanent quotidien de
très jeunes femmes après le jt personne
ne s'est posé la question de ce qui se
passait dans ce bureau à 21h mâts pales
responsable de la sécurité qui est dans
le dans le documentaire dire
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que ça on se
poserait cette piste et fort ce que des
murs il y en a besoin
le 3 mars 2021 tp des rites invité chez
quotidien l'ex présentateur du jt de 20h
sur tf1 était alors on est accusé par
florence porcel journalistes et autres
estime de viol commis entre 2004 et 2009
une affaire révélée voilà le par
libération le 19 février 2021 vous avez
révélé dans libération qui ont une
interview à déclencher votre envie de
témoigner c'est quand vous l'avez vu sur
le plateau de quotidiens vous êtes dit
ouais je là j'ai envie déjà envie de
donner moi c'est ce qui a déclenché mon
envie de témoigner parce que
c'est vrai qu'après ces dernières années
j'en ai un peu parlé quand même autour
de moi vous avez reparlé quelques
personnes dont un de vos chroniqueurs
que je ne nommerai pas ce soir mais
quel était votre question par comment
savoir si
vous avez vous avez vous commencé quand
vous l'avez vu du sud / quotidien vous
avez quotidien pardon excusez moi
quotidien oui parce que quotidien quand
même les petits bisous dans le cou
[Musique]
voilà c'était l'extrémisme il fallait
pas d'ailleurs c'est pour moi c'est un
manque de stratégie total c'est à dire
que plainte était classée sans suite
quand même
aujourd'hui les plaines s'est plaint de
son classée sans suite le procureur n'a
pas souhaité poursuivre donc si vous
voulez quotidien pour il l'a fait
ensuite il a porté plainte pour
dénonciation calomnieuse à l'encontre de
florence parce alors justement et donc
si vous voulez oui quand j'ai vu
quotidiens comme la plupart d'entre nous
d'ailleurs quand on a vu quotidien on
s'est dit non mais là c'est pas possible
ça va trop loin oui vous êtes également
le protège encore alors ce quotidien
c'est quand même le groupe stef ci
donnera méritait un peu bizarre il est
tout seul il n'ya plus d'amitié ouais
mais bon bah là bas il faut le dire bien
sûr on peut ne pas donner la parole aux
si vous aimez ça après
si on a pu noter qu est ce qu a versé
qu'il a parlé en parlant de bisous dans
le cou etc et puis la dénonciation
calomnieuse parce qu'il avait encore ce
sentiment toute puissance et d'impunité
j'étais dans le déni absolu c'est à dire
que il nie les ont daigné pour lui ça
n'a pas existé
et puis il a une notion du consentement
qui est quand même très particulier à je
ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire le
consentement alors ok consentement c'est
assez nouveau dans les réflexions c'est
vrai que mis tous et 2017 c'est vrai que
les féministes et 2019 on se rend pas
compte mais c'est très très riches entre
toutes ces notions d'ailleurs jeu 30e
fait medici d'aujourd'hui
donc si vous voulez je pense que la
motion de contenants lui est totalement
étrangère totalement
réaliste c'est ce que vous a choqué
oulaye et un instant c'est sur les
bisous dans le cou
voilà pour vous ici c'est voilà il ya
aucune conscience en fait du
consentement c'est ce que vous dites
mais quand vous êtes quand vous êtes que
quand vous avez quand votre supérieur
hiérarchique ou fait des petits bisous
dans le cou enfin est ce que c'est
normal puis enfin ce que vous faites des
petits bisous dans le cou à toutes deux
chroniqueuses
tout l'appartement des tic quand même en
tournée d'halloween et où sa
voix c'est un comportement irréprochable
problème c'est surtout qu'ils me font
des bisous dans le cou et autonome vous
savez comme les c'est vrai oui gilles et
quand on vous entend muriel il faut dire
les choses il ya une protection de la
chaîne maintenant il faut il faut le
dire cartes sur table c'est pas possible
ce sentiment d'impunité je finis le 20
heures je ferme mon bureau à clé
j'adresse des jeunes femmes
successivement c'est impossible que la
chaîne au delà de l'appel que vous
faites à patrick le lay c'est impossible
que ses assistants des trous d'air et
moynier c'est impossible gilles bouleau
je veux même pas en parler parce que
voilà mais c'est impossible qu'il n'y
ait pas eu un système de protection de
ppda au nom de l'audience d'intérêt
économique c'est ça non mais c'est cette
vous révéler aussi là en fait c'est
impossible autrement vous avez vu dans
le documentaire oui j'écoute a dit il
était impensable de se séparer de
patrick poivre d'arvor la mémoire vous
savez et je ne dis pas que tout le monde
savait sûrement même pas dire ce que je
sais d'où je ne sais pas je dis qu'on
s'est pas interrogé sur ce mouvement
permanent quotidien systématique de
jeunes femmes jamais d'hommes toujours
des jeunes femmes sur un plateau donc
fatalement vous étiez moi je suis revenu
en 2008 c'était un secret de
polichinelle honnêtement tout le monde
sa mais va en 2008 où le cheval à
l'agression mais oui tout le monde sait
qu
il y avait un système emas thème de deux
il y avait un système vous connaissez le
système de victimes été mis en place
pour effectivement ramené deux des
jeunes filles vous savez très bien tous
les systèmes un prédateur non le système
et on connaissait tous
si vraiment à
l'époque on avait dit à des amis de la
chaîne effectivement on fait attention
on n'y va pas problème ascenseur c'était
tout le monde le savait c'est pas vrai
j'aurais juste dans sa déclaration
devant le major quand il a été convoqué
il dit le majeur lui pose la question et
lui dit vous aviez des relations
sexuelles dans votre bureau qu'en pensez
vous sa réponse est oui c'était normal
d'avoir des relations sexuelles dans mon
bureau peut-être qu'aujourd'hui je
ferais différemment mais non ça n'a pas
choqué dans quelle entreprise on a des
relations sexuelles enfin bureau
quand même
bien que vous étiez tf1 aussi allez pas
vous mais moi j'étais à tf1 en 4 98 81
18 juste musique avec benjamin
d'ailleurs jusqu'en 2010 mais en
l'occurrence moi je suis une des
assistantes de patrick ouart d'abord qui
au moment de la préparation du passage à
l'an 2000 m'a appelé parce que j'avais
fait la première conférence de rédaction
pour préparer ce passage à l'an 2000 et
à la suite de cette première réunion où
je découvre moi le grand patrick poivre
d'arvor je suis une jeune journaliste et
j'arrive du divertissement plus donc je
suis un peu tu très très très flatté à
la suite de ça je suis dans ma voiture
au retour de cette réunion j'ai un coup
de fil de cette assistante qui me dit
patrick souhaiterait déjeuner avec vous
et moi je suis flatté et à aucun moment
on me prévient où on me dit attention
c'est dangereux en revanche ce qu'on me
dit c'est ah ouais toi aussi tu dragues
mais il te drague il te dragon donc ils
te drac bombe a très bien joué si
éventuellement il va me draguer je vais
repoussé ses avances et en l'occurrence
effectivement nous avons déjeuné à deux
reprises et à deux reprises il a été
charmant charmeur mais pas je me suis
jamais sentie en danger donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai pas le même
sens nous au niveau de la justice us
alors la police judiciaire enquête est
là elle est en train de vouloir élargir
c'est à dire qu'il ya toutes les
plaintes et puis ça en train de voir
s'il n'ya pas d'anciennes affaires et
une nouvelle affaire je vais vous
révéler que par exemple il ya un faits
de harcèlement sexuel qui daterait jeu
mais le conditionnel de 2014
qui va être mis à jour alors 2014 s'il y
en a près les derniers actes dont on a
entendu parler qui s'arrêtait à 2009
donc c'est prescrit sans doute mais si
ça continue jusqu'en 2014 ce que veut le
savoir les policiers c est ce qu il n'y
aurait pas encore après des actes qui ne
seraient pas prescrits après ils
travaillent vraiment ils reprennent tout
le dossier à zéro parce qu'il faut
rappeler que le sert pas à zéro donc
tout le monde est reconvoqué tout le
monde témoigne de nouveau là si je peux
faire un petit point sur les spectateurs
en complément de ce que vous dites
monsieur sait que effectivement les deux
premières plaintes de ppda de patrie
port d'abord ont été classées sans suite
cela signifie que le procureur n'a pas
voulu poursuivre il a aussi classé notre
place pour prescription pas pour faits
non réalisés pour prescription
florence porcel a déposé plainte à
nouveau avec constitution de partie
civile cette affaire là cette
inscription là est en cours avec des
juges d'instruction
ppda vient de déposer plainte à déposer
une première fois plainte contre nous ça
a été classée sans suite il a il vient
de re déposé plainte contre nous c'est à
dire qu'une ourse et quotidien il vient
de re déposé plainte contre 16 femme
pour dénonciation calomnieuse
avec constitution de partie civile
d'accord géant parallèle de cela c'est
vrai comme il ya eu d'autres témoignages
il y a à nouveau une enquête
préliminaire qui est en cours dont il ya
deux affaires même 3-1 et unia une
enquête préliminaire qui continue sur
les nouveaux témoignages et je dois dire
que si je peux le dire c'est que cette
nouvelle plainte de ppda contre cette
femme eh bien nous serons ravis d'aller
au tribunal n'ont adopté moitié mâle
ouvert
mais moi tu vois j'aurai le sentiment de
raymond qui est vraiment extérieur a
tout vu de l'extérieur si ça paraît
curieux que j'entends ce que tu dis va
ériger j'entends ce que ni berlin vous
étiez tous les deux chez enfin je peux
pas mettre en cause sa parier que ça
paraît quand même curieux du deck sorte
que personne ne soit au courant moi
c'est mon avis personnel ça va mieux que
gilles bouleau soit pas au courant on
parle de cette femme-là fort quand même
faut être costaud dans la tête pour
porter plainte contre cette femme lui il
décide de porter plainte contre cette
femme parce qu'il estime que c'est cette
femme raconte des bêtises pour les
intimider dénonciation calomnieuse mais
c'est pas vraiment toute la question
c'est la différence entre une dragueur
yoyo l'appréciation exactement le même
procédé pour répondre à ta question
faire voilà les gens doivent tout à
l'heure mais il a raison hugo ces salles
a dit oui mais tout à l'heure madame
disaient les relations sexuelles au
travail dans un bureau oui ça peut
arriver c'est qu'on sent si on ferme pas
l'aspect accueillant nago enfin mais
attendait les roses annonça par saborio
et garder ses sont sentis ça peut bien
entraver aujourd'hui dans tous mes des
entreprises dans toutes les entreprises
que je connais et pour lesquels dans
lesquels je viens de faire bien je peux
vous dire que drh sanctionne oui non
peut-être oui non mais non ça sans que
jamais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
bien de finir de
6,26 ya bien un truc qui va avec a dit
loeb dès qu'on le mette dans les abrutis
mais sur un de simba celui-là non mais
26 femmes qui portent pas juste après
ces options c'est la prescription ça
c'est le 11 mai 2021 trois jours après
la mise en ligne de l'enquète de
libération l'association mitu médias a
été créée vous et quatre autres victimes
hélène devynck emmanuelle dancourt
cécile ti moreau et cécile delarue vous
avez fondé cette association ensemble
mitu médias ça c'est important pour vous
c'est important parce que ça permet de
recueillir la parole des femmes ce qui
s'est passé ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
au quotidien là on reçoit énormément de
témoignages tous les jours on a des
témoignages c'est pour ça qu'on dise que
je vous donne sont des chiffres
officiels moi je donne que les chiffres
relevés par les services de police
d'accord je m'aventure pas sur le reste
mais peux vous dire quand même que nous
avons énormément de personnes qui nous
appellent pour témoigner en tout cas
pour nous raconter des faits similaires
donc oui tout média c1 comment dire un
cadre pour pouvoir accueillir la parole
des victimes commençâmes d'ailleurs dans
les médias